[Music]
okay so the tactics are basically the
end of the game and their little three
to eight move combinations where the
side with the advantage breaks through
the enemy defenses to win the game this
first examples on the screen and
tonight's topic is attacking the King
Knight pawn the enemies King Knight pawn
most of the examples of the pawn will be
on the King Knight 2 square or if it's
black the g7 square later on there's a
few examples where the pawns on King
Knight 3 r g6 square this is our first
example and it's white to play and win
so it you can see that the White Knight
that's sitting on the f5 square is
conveniently attacking our target pawn
on g7 the black pawn on g7 also we have
a nicely placed white bishop on the g5
square attacking the f6 Knight and the
Queen is hovering on e 2 ready to pounce
up that white diagonal toward the black
King side and then to top it off we have
a nicely placed a white bishop on the B
3 square attacking the black defender on
e6 so those are all the elements that we
need to have a successful attack for
white the question is what is the proper
sequence to move and I'll leave it up to
the audience to suggest a winning move
for white that's right he has nothing
better than pawn takes and now what
on e6 and there's no stop to the Queen
the g4 check followed by mate but
there's a way to avoid mate
what would how would black avoid
checkmate oh yeah but we can take the
bishop and avoid mate we take it with
the pawn then the Queen comes up and if
the King moves up or over to the corner
Queen to G sevens mate but we can block
it with the black Queen and then we have
Knight to e7 check and we pick the Queen
up and win that way okay let's go to our
next example obviously white is the one
attacking blacks King Knight 7 again
yeah this is pretty straightforward who
would like to suggest the winning move
for white this time Bishop takes f6
could well win I'm going to say that if
you did that black could reply Queen
takes Knight on f5 threatening Queen
takes bishop so there's a better way to
win than Bishop takes f6 any other
suggestions
well that doesn't work as the Queen can
go back and just take the knight Knight
takes h6 that's the right idea very
forceful pawn takes now we take the
knight on f6 with the bishop and it
conveniently protects our rook then we
threaten something like Rick to g4 check
picking up the Queen so he moves the
Queen now he's threatening our bishop
what's the winning move here for well
White's already winning because we have
an attack where it White's the pawn up
all the pieces are well our white
squared Bishop isn't developed but it'll
be developed soon blacks Knights still
on it's hope its first square so that
hasn't moved Queen the g4 doesn't work
because if Queen takes Queen rook takes
Queen Bishop takes Queen so who would
have another suggestion
this may seem very simplistic I think
it's Queen to e5 just straight you trade
Queens in you have a winning attack but
let's see if there's something else well
then he asked Queen takes Bishop don't
forget he's threatening Queen takes
Bishop on f6 so let's see what the oh
it's it's not Queen to e5 better is
Queen to f3 why is Queen to f3 better
than Queen to e5 both moves allow the
trade of whites Queen and would seem to
weaken White's attack why is Queen f3
the stronger move well the answer is
what happens after Queen takes Queen
pawn takes Queen opening up the King
Knight file and then there's a nasty
check on g1 check whereas if we had
played Queen to e5 he could trade Queens
and move his Knight to d7 where it's
protected by the bishop and attacked the
bishop on the e5 forcing the bishop to
retreat and there's no open knight file
with a killer check on g1 so so that's
the answer so here he brings his knight
up now we get a little pretty we just
take it Bishop takes Queen here check he
can block it either way the answer is
almost the same so Queen to g4 is a
little better
what's the winning move here for white
we're actually down the exchange so we
have to have a winning attack at this
point who has a suggested move for white
well f3 is okay but let's how about can
we bring another piece to the attack and
we bring our bishop on f1 that's not
doing anything and attack blacks
position e to a queen can't take it the
Queen's pinned and if Queen takes Queen
it opens up our rook file and we have
rook takes pawn on h6 and there's no
stopping earth to h8 checkmate so he
retreats the Queen now what's the
winning move it's the same bishop but it
moves to another square
Bishop to h5 is probably okay but why
not go to d3 where you attack the Queen
and you also cover the h7 square that's
better than h5 on h5 you don't cover the
h7 square so here it is now if he goes
back to g4 now we play f3 and he has to
do Queen takes Queen because he can't
retreat we open up and then we got Rick
takes pawn and rook to h8 checkmate so
that's it that's pretty much it okay
okay so again it's white is attacking
blacks g7 square and we have a bishop on
c3 attacking the g7 square protected by
our queen now black has a knight on e4
he can take our bishop
it doesn't do him a lot of good because
we just take with the queen and then our
queen attacks g7 we have a Rick on g1
it's pointed toward g7 there's only one
slight drawback what would that drawback
be V the V our work on g1 as it pertains
to attacking the g7 pond
she forced the move the drawback is the
pawn is in the way of the route so we
got to get rid of a pawn the best move
is g4 this is the case I'm going through
examples
the art of chess combinations by
Eugene's NASSCO borovsky a Russian this
book was written in 1936 before
computers came out and he actually
proposes not the strongest move his move
is Bishop takes pawn
what do that first that will go back to
the strongest King takes and then g4
then the king moves over pawn takes pawn
takes Knight comes up check King back
rook takes pawn we're on the Queen and
the knight and our work and go to g7 and
then threaten rook takes Knight
checkmate so that's pretty much it
but let's let's go back now and see what
white should have done Bishop to g7 does
is a good move in that it leads to a
white advantage but you see the plus
over equal sign on the notation there
that's a slight advantage for white
if white had played your move
g4 he would have had a winning advantage
so this is the correct move and the
computer pointed it out so the plus
minus symbol is the winning advantage
for white the plus is on the left so
they do the whites it's a plus for white
a - for black that's a winning advantage
for white see we don't we're better off
not sacrificing the bishop because we
open up the G file and then we have our
bishop and the threat is rook takes pawn
check that's the strongest way to attack
blacks best is to eliminate the bishop
then the Queen comes up now he doesn't
have a way to block it and if he does
Rick to f7 we can attack the work with
Knight to g5 threatening Knight takes
rook anyway
black can try rook to c8 now you would
think G pawn takes on f5 is the best
move but the computer says not so fast I
bet most players wouldn't see this move
white should bring up his pawn the h4 he
has plenty of time no 'pn
the G file that pawn is going to advance
the h6 if it's not stopped then pawn
takes pawn will be a winning combination
black really because blacks you see
black is blocked his pawns his D pawn is
on the second on his second row or the
d7 square it blocks the Queen and rook
so there's nothing in black and black
can't get his pieces where they can
attack white and he can't get his pieces
over to defend the King side either he
brings his queen up we advanced the rip
pawn again now black tries d5 that opens
up the second row for the Queen it comes
across the knight does block the Queen
but the Queen is at least aiming toward
g7 we just do pawn takes black does
Knight takes attacking our queen he
drives the Queen off the g7 square Queen
goes up to G for now the knight can't
really move because the white queen
would take the e6 pawn with check black
does pawn takes g4 rook takes pawn check
is very strong it's not checked rook
takes pawn is very strong attacking the
g7 square but there's an even better
move the knight comes up to g5 notice
it's attacking that weak pawn on e6
which is undefended Knight takes c6
threatens the knight fork on the Queen
and rook winning the exchange in a pawn
black brings the Queen up it defends the
e6 pawn but notice that the White Queen
and rook are on the d5 Knight the only
thing protecting the d5 Knight is the e6
pawn so we take the e6 pawn
Queen takes but now we get the night
back Queen takes rook takes and we've
got a winning rook and pawn ending White
has two four six pawns black right now
has two four five pawns but black has
two pawns being attacked at the same
time the pawn on g4 oh well the pot on
g4 black does defend the pawn on c5 but
he can't protect the pawn on g4 White
will be two pawns up and black has no
counter-attacks cuz his rooks are poorly
placed and this is an easy one in being
so that's how the game should of God but
going back the author had Bishop takes
pawn king takes g4 now black played King
to f7 see those two question marks one
question mark is a bad move two question
marks is a very bad move or a blunder
and it's a losing blunder the plus minus
means White has a one position after the
King go staff seven black could have
avoided checkmate had he played his King
to the corner see then if the rook takes
the pawn on g7 and the knight goes to e5
he's he doesn't he doesn't get the
winning check see when he went to f7 he
gave White Knight to e5 check and then
Rick takes d7 pun by going to h8 he
doesn't give white the check so white
opens up the G file for the rook and he
doesn't go to e5 now he goes to g5
he's simply threatening Knight takes
Knight pawn takes Knight Queen takes
pawn and or know it that's not his
threat his threat is Knight to e6 see
the rook here pins the pawn on g7 so
Knight to e6 would fork the Queen and
rook and that would win for white black
plays Knight to f6 Knight to e6 Queen to
b6 we picked the RIC up and we move our
King to a safe spot and White has the
better chances White has 2 4 7 pawns
Black has 5 so White's two pawns ahead
but Black has two knights which is six
points or six pawns and versus the rook
which is five so black gets upon there
he was two pawns down but he gets a plus
pawn for the two Knights versus the Rick
he's one pawn down it's an advantage for
white but according to the computer it
may not be a winning advantage it's a
it's a slight advantage in the nd ok so
that's the case we're having the
computer solved the problem nicely and
the author was a little bit slide by
what happened in the game where white
took the pawn and stronger at which
would have won immediately was leaving
the bishop there I'm just opening up the
G file ok
this is the little twist everything
we've looked at so far white wins with
an attack on the king Knight to pawn the
g7 pawn for black this time black wins
you can tell that black is the one
attacking the white G to pawn his a
knight on h4 attacking the pawn on g2
notice the nice placement of blacks
bishops there on D 76 by each other and
they come down and they attack white and
black squares on the King side notice
that the black rooks are side by side
and the rook on EI detects the bishop on
the e2 and notice that the black queen
is on d5 in the middle of the board
attacking f3 and aiming to the g2 pawn
and then look at White's position
White's night is on f3 defending that's
his most advanced piece his next piece
is the bishop on e2 merely defending the
knight threatening nothing and White's
queen is on his a beginning square but
White's black squared Bishop is on the
beginning square and White's rook is on
in the corner white totally missed
played the opening and he's going to
lose the game because of it guess who
black is he's the famous world champion
who won the world championship in 1894
and held it for 27 years until 1921 who
was that German world champion who know
that was the gap this guy beat Stein
it's
jibber hear of a manual asker anyway
Alaska was black and he was a great
world champion he held the record 27
years and he was famous for his
attacking but and his endgame ability
let's see what he does here I don't
remember exactly what black does he
sacks the night for the g2 pawn that's
our theme attacking the pawn king takes
now there's a pretty follow-up would
anyone in the audience care to suggest a
winning move for black Alaska or was not
afraid to sacrifice multiple pieces the
work pawn yep that's the right move well
here oh okay
so in the game we took the bishop right
then the Queen came up to f5 but if he
goes here now black moves his pawn up
he's going to attack the knight in the
king with his King side pawns is gonna
play g5 and then g4 Rick over pawn up he
has nothing better than to give up the
bishop to take the pawns so he gives
back the piece then he wouldn't take
with the night that would open up to
Rick to f8 check so he takes with the
Rick he's attacking the Queen Queen
moves back now the Queen is threatening
Queen the e3 check he moves the Queen up
to guard the e3 Square the bishop comes
in attacking the rook and he has the
possible Bishop to e3 check protected by
the Queen and rook
white tries to counter-attack on the
bishop black just takes the rook Knight
takes now the Queen comes over check
attacking the knight so the knight s I
was thinking the knight had to go back
Bishop comes up but that just does okay
then if Queen takes Knight rook takes
Bishop so he black pulls in the bishop
back now he's on the night in the queen
so the knight takes the pawn he's on the
Queen the Queen moves over is on the
knight
now the rook comes over attacking the
knight in the night had the knight okay
that's that's pretty much it the knight
can't move because the answer would be
[Music]
would probably be Rick takes rook and
then the work to g8 would threaten the
the Queen down to g1 check which would
win okay
that was fairly complicated that'll do
it for tonight thanks for coming
[Music]
you
you